humans have been improving grains fruits
vegetables ever since we started growing
them
we crossed and selected plants picking
the right characteristics to get better
crops new genomic techniques allow us to
do the same faster and with more
Precision the techniques identify and
select the right characteristics from
the plant's own DNA or from a related
plant like a different variety of potato
this way you can develop a potato that
survives a lengthy drought or a tomato
with more defenses against pests with
droughts heat waves new pests we need
all hands on deck the updated rules make
it possible to use new genomic
techniques in a safe way European
consumers can keep eating safe
nutritious and tasty food and farmers
can deal with the impacts of climate
change and biodiversity loss and reduce
the chemicals that harm our health and
the environment